ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد تتواصلوا
المعارك في مدينه فوليدار بين الجيشين
الاوكراني والروسيه الذي يحاول تحقيقا
انتصار كبير في الشرق ليقترب من تحقيق اول
اختراق في ميدان المعركه منذ سته اشهر
فباستخدام المرتزقه فاجنر 9 روسيا هذه
المره لاحكام السيطره على مدينه سوليدار
تمهيدا لتطويق مدينه باخ موت
الاستراتيجيات ومن ثم فتح الطريق امام
الجيش الروسي لتحقيق التواصل مع المدن
الكبرى في منطقتين
مجموعه فاجر دورا رئيسيه في معركه باخمود
حيث اشارت صحيفه واشنطن بوست لنحو 40
تجميدهم وارسالهم الى القتال في اوكرانيا
مع مجموعه شبه العسكري الجيش الاوكراني
يواجه هجمات المتعدده في سوليدار من طرف
مرتزقه حيث بات تلك المدينه هي اكثر نقاط
سخونه على جبهه المعارك منذ شهر فبراير
الماضي التقدم والانتصارات التي يعلنها
مرتزقه فاجنر في سوليدار اثارت التساؤلات
حول سبب استعانه موسكو بها وهل لانها
الاقدر على الحسم ام لان انتهاكاتها في
المعارك لن تساءل عنها الدوله الروسيه
[موسيقى]
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفي
مكنته مستشار وزير الخارجيه الاوكرانيه
اهلا بكم
المحلل العسكري
بخصوص العديد من الاسئله من بدايه ظهورها
في 2014 مع مرحله القرم فيما بعد رايناها
في ليبيا في سوريا في 2015 في ليبيا في
ليبيا في 2016
كذلك سؤال المطروح لماذا تزوج بها روسيا
في معاركها ما الاضافه التي تقدمها ولماذا
الاستعانه بها
مساء الخير وتحيه
مع تسميه المقاتلين مجموعه مرتزقه
نعم هم يحصلون رواتبهم واا
عندهم مخصصات ولكن في هذه الحاله الجيش
محترف يمكن تسميتهم همم جماعه المرتزقه
همم
قلت بانهم يتلقون رواتب فهو سيذهب
للاسترزاق هو سيوقع هناك حتى من اسمائهم
جنودا للايجار
ااا عفوا
للعلم والاطلاع
راتب اي مجلد روسي تم دخوله في الجيش
مؤخرا ضمن
تابع الجزئيه يزيد على راتب مقاتل في
جماعه بغداد
اكثر من ذلك لا يمكن دخول همم وحدات جماعه
همم الا من قبل محترفين يعني همم
الخبره العسكريه
والقتاليه الحقيقيه
وعندهم اختصاص مطلوب في ميدان المعركه
يعني لا يمكن اي واحد يتوه ويروح ويقاتل
من اجل ابدا هذا همم
مستحيل نعم همم
حتى داخل المجتمع همم
الروسي
لان قانونيه يعني همم شركه امنيه خاصه همم
وشركه عسكريه خاصه مثل جماعه بابنر
والمعلوم ان عندهم اسلحه ثقيله وحتى
الطيران الحربي ولا اخرهم همم لا يذكر اي
شيء مثل هذا في القوانين الروسيه همم
عليهم لانه لبعض يقول الاستخبارات الروسيه
لبعض الاخر يقول لك
هذا هو ابن اسرار جماعه بغداد المعلوم ان
هذه الجماعه مدعومه ماديه وماليا وسياسيا
وقانونيا من قبل اسادات الروسيه لولا هذا
لا يمكن ان يحصل
زعيم هذه الجماعه على اعلى وسام روسيا وهو
بطل روسيا ويظهر على شاشات التلفزيون واا
ظهر على شاشه التلفزيون ولكن اكد فقط من
تفصيل صحيح انه كان طباخ لبوتين
روايات وهناك همم اقوال همم نعم همم
الصحيح انه كان همم لانه في الواقع سالت
لانه شاهدنا صوره لبوتين وهو مع هذا
الظابط طبعا ويقال بان فاجنر سميت على اسم
على اسم الحركي لهذا الضابط لما كان ينتمي
لوحدات الجيش الروسيه ولكن خليني يعني
اكتب بس منك همم توصيفك لهذه المجموعه قلت
بانها شركه خاصه سيد همم
بحسب قراءتك لماذا يستعين الجانب الروسي
بشركه خاصه لتامين مع ريكه الحد
مساء الخير
واحده مهمه الان ممكن القول هناك مسابقه
في روسيا مسابقه حتى في الجيش الروسي
مشاركه واحده
العسكريه الموجوده الان في الجبهه هناك
شركه على الاقل واحده كمان واسمها
شركه مواليه او تحت رعايه السيد وزير
الدفاع
يعني مسابقه
مستمره في قياده الجيش الروسي
متعودين على مسابقه
عن شركه الصقور عن شركه اخرى همم يستعين
بها الجيش الروسي ولكن خلينا مع شركه فاجن
لان فاجنر لها تاريخ تبعنا عمليه القتاليه
في ليبيا في سوريا هو اليوم في اوكرانيا
بحسب قراءتك لماذا تستعين او يستعين الجيش
الروسي بهذه المجموعه
والله سؤال ايلي نعم
انا افتكر بيننا
اللي كانت يعني مؤلمه في شهر سبتمبر افتكر
انسان الماضيه هاي التعب مش ال الاخيره في
روسيا والمؤلقين يتحدثون الان عن التعبئه
الثانيه والقادمه خلال ايام القادم امبارح
وافق لما معلومات تم اصدار القرار غير
مؤلم حتى الان بمعنى مغادره روسيا اللي
همم
رجال الذين عندهم حق وعندهم واجب ان همم
يخدمون بالجيش هذه صحيح ام لا انا ما بعرف
لسه ههه
الوقت والضيق الاسلحه والديك المعدات
التاليه
قناه الجيش الروسي بفاكنر بموضوع التعبئه
ولكن خلينا ندخل في بعض الانتقادات سيد
شوشكوف البعض يقول بان استعانه بوتين
بيفاجنار هو لان
فاجنر تقوم بالاعمال الغير نظيفه همم سطو
اختصاب قتل فحتى لا تساءل الجهه الرسميه
الروسيه على هذه الاعمال في روسيا تقحم
مجموعات تاجرها لفعل ذلك
هكذا
انك تبيعي بكير
يعني الحكايات مثل هذه تصدر يوميا من كيف
اا
تقول انه جماعه فخده وحتى الجيش الروسي كل
ما يقوم به هو الاختصاب
والقتل ولماذا الجماعيه وهمم
الوحيده التي قالت هذا الكلام الاتحاد
الاوروبي اصدر عقوبات على فاجنر بعد
عمليات قتاليه ادارتها هذه المجموعه في
ليبيا وتورطت بحسب الاتحاد الاوروبي في
عمليات سطته قتل واختصار
عجيب تفضل
الثقافه والفن والموسيقى القطط الروسيه
التاريخ اللغه الروسيه الى العمل
الاولمبيه اي شيء روسي اصبح ممنوع في
قرارات الاتحاد الاوروبي وفي قمه حلف
بنيته صار قرار انه روسي الاول للغرب
عندما همم
هناك اتهامات نسمع اتهامات
بالجيش الروسي ودول الروسيه واي روسيه
لحتى جنسيه روسيه همم صارت موضوع همم
الاتحاد باي شيء باي شيء همم
صراحه اتعجب ولو متواضع
اتهامات الاتحاد الاوروبي لمجموعه ليست
منذ بدا العمليه او كما تسميها روسيا
العمليه العسكريه المحدوده على اوكرانيا
وحدثك في ليبيا منذ 2016 يعني كانت هناك
همم تاكيدات على ان هذه المجموعات تقترف
ما لا تقترف الجيوش ومن هنا اتتساؤل لماذا
يقحم بوتن بهذه المجموعات في القتال
واشنطن الى اخره همم
وحتى من من ترابلس بالضغط همم من الغرب
انه جماعه همم
يقاتلون في همم في الخندق همم جماعه تربل
والى اخره
هل هناك اسير واحد
6000 من جماعه بغداد سته الاف مقاتلين هل
هناك اسير 1 هل هناك جريح واحد هل هناك
قتيل واحد هل هناك اي شيء موثوق ام مجرد
روايات
وتصريحات واقوال
[موسيقى]
حربيه
او في سوريا
موجوده يعني اسطوره الذين يستعملوها يعني
كانت دعايه للجيش الروسي وقد دعايه لبطاله
روسيه والاخره
ونحن نتذكر جيدا جدا اييه هاي مجموعه بقدر
افريقيا
ومن مدن اخرى ما هو النتائج يعني همم
هذه مجموعه في سوريا
وكان سوريين الان تركوا بيوتهم ويشوفوا
الصور
حضرتك بقول بانه هذه المجموعه
ما المقصود بان هذه المجموعه اسطوره يعني
تريد ان تقول بانها اكذب بانها هناك
مبالغه في وصفها لتخويف مثلا
والله انا مش خبير زي حضره العقيد مش خبير
في شؤون العسكريه ولكن مع ذلك
ما شاركتوش ولكن حضرتوا كثير من الحروب
خصوصا في الدول العربيه في لبنان في
العراق في سوريا في ليبيا
واتذكر بنا هناك كانت في اوقات يعني حتى
في ثمانينات
في القرن الماضي كانوا متتوعين من كثير من
الدول
ولكن واحد رجل اعمال سيد جوشن هو جاهه
يعني فكره
تنظيم هذه متطوعين الى الى مجموعات اللي
هو بيحكم عليها
اها للاستعانه بهم يعني حضرتك دائما تربط
بين الاستعانه بهذا المجموعات بعمليه
التعبئه واا ربما البحث عن اعداد اخرى
ولكن سيد شاشكوف همم اذا ما تورطت روسيا
الرسميه
من وراء او نتيجه
لدفعها بهذه المجموعه كيف ستكون اتابعها
روسيا
اعلانات
في هذه الى ماليه العسكريه في في 23 من
شباط الماضي الموضوع الاسم موضوع جماعه
ولو هذا هو موضوع لقاء اليوم الموضوع اكثر
واكبر بكثير وليس بالصدفه تم تعيين اليوم
قبل ساعه تقريبا همم
وهو رئيس هيئه اركان الجيش في القوات
المسلحه الروسيه
قائدا ميدانيا لهذه الماليه
وهو قائد السلاح الجوي
القوات الفضائيه يعني هذا قوه كل يؤشر على
ان الموضوع يعني
مع كل تقديري واحتمال واحترامي لجهودهم في
ميدان المعركه
بالمناسبه اليوم صباح اليوم
اشاره خصيصا لان جمعت بغداد هي التي تخوض
المعركه في سلدار وهي التي حرر سوليدار
وهي التي حققت هذا النجاح الكبير في سندار
وهو قال هذا تكرارا وميرارا ولكن اخذت
الجبهه اكثر من 800 كيلومتر والجماعه مجره
واحده فرعيه
واحده من
الكثير من الوحدات والتشكيلات
القتاليه التي تشارك في هذه الى ماليه
همم نعم هناك تساؤلات بتبيعه عامل بايرنر
ولكن
يعني تساؤلات عديده صحيحه
سنتبعها سنفتح النقاش
لمتابعه هذا ملفه وشكرك على الحضور وعلى
المشاركه من موسكو سيرجي
العسكريه ومنك يافا
مستشار وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني شكرا لكم